As we commemorate the first anniversary of the Great East Japan Earthquake,
together with the people gathered here today,
I would like to express my deepest condolences to the families of the many
people who lost their lives in this earthquake.
A year ago today, Japan was unexpectedly struck by a huge earthquake and tsunami,
which resulted in almost twenty thousand dead and missing persons.
We must not forget that this included many people, such as fire fighters,
who lost their lives as they devoted themselves to relief operations
and disaster control without regard for their own safety.
As this earthquake and tsunami caused the nuclear power plant accident,
those living in areas designated as the danger zone lost their homes
and livelihoods, and had to leave the places they used to live.
In order for them to live there again safely,
we have to overcome the problem of radioactive contamination, which is a formidable task.
After the earthquake, many people, including members of the Government
and of the local authorities as well as many volunteers,
went to the afflicted areas and carried out various efforts to support the afflicted people.
I am sure their activities helped to comfort the evacuees living under harsh conditions
and encouraged them to think positively about the future.
I would like to take this opportunity to express my deepest gratitude
to the people who have worked for the afflicted people
and ravaged regions, and to those who have been trying to
contain the damage from the nuclear power plant accident.
Many people overseas responded to the disaster
by sending us relief teams and offering us help in various ways.
In many cables of sympathy that I received from the foreign heads of state,
they commented on how truly impressed they were by how, under severe conditions,
the afflicted people were helping each other and
working towards reconstruction with a strong sense of solidarity.
I am deeply grateful for the kindness shown by the people around the world.
It is expected that many difficult challenges lie ahead in the reconstruction of the afflicted areas.
It is my hope that the people's hearts will always be with the afflicted people and regions,
and that everyone will continue to work towards improving the conditions of those areas.
It is important for us to never forget this disaster and to learn the lessons for the future generations,
and foster the proper attitude towards disaster prevention, in the aim of making our country a safer place.
In closing, I would like to express my hope that Japan will become once again
a country where people can live with a sense of security
and again offer my sincere condolences for all those who lost their lives in the Great East Japan Earthquake.